[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I'm your
host for today Jade warshaw and I'm
joined by the man the Marvel George
Campbell I was like where are we going
with this George
they're magnificent this is why you want
to hang out with Jade she makes you feel
great well you are great George you're a
great guy a great co-worker and uh we're
taking your calls all day long at least
for the next three hours that is and uh
Colin with whatever it is you want to
talk about we're talking about life
we're talking about money trying to
stick to the budget trying to pay off
debt trying to buy some real estate
whatever it might be put the kids
through college whatever it is please
give us a call the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and let's go on right directly to these
phone lines because we've got Landon in
Memphis Tennessee what's going on Landon
M tone hey how's it going hey how's it
going doing good how are you doing well
um so I just want to get y'all the
opinion on something that might be
absolutely ludicrous oh my goodness um
prefers to prefer to get y'all's
opinions anyways
um so I just made a career change about
seven months ago I became a realtor
after leaving a job that I was at for
about since I was 12 actually wow
um and my wife works a salary job and so
obviously with meeting a realtor my
income can go drastically up or down
um so for my first couple of months
didn't make a whole lot and then this
month I made 32 Grand next month I'll
make about 25 and then I'm working a 9
million dollar deal and so whoa hold up
did you say 9 million
yes that's right I can I what is it can
I ask
uh it's a commercial property wow
yeah that is Luda so keep going
obviously so obviously one month you
know I could make really good money in
the next month I might you know make not
much and so my question is is it a good
idea for my wife to quit her salary job
to be a state-own mom what she
desperately wants to do and just you
know stick with my commission only
um job how long so you may have said
this before but I got sidetracked by the
9 million how long have you been doing
real estate seven months seven months
and how much money is your wife making
right now
like 45 or 50 Grand
here's what I would here's I'm always
going to tell you what Jade warshaw
might do
um if I were in your exact situation in
your exact shoes I think that you're
probably on track to be able to do that
but you're so early in the game on this
I would want to just get a whole picture
of what a whole year is like and say
okay like is this normal did I have just
a couple of quick windfalls what's it
like you know does that make sense
because I feel like real estate is one
of those things so many people got into
real estate George in 2020 and it was
like huh I can do this like this is easy
you know and then the market started
getting different and it was like oh
this is what it's really like yeah it
went from any one of their mom could
sell houses and make good money to oh my
gosh even the pros are struggling right
and it sounds like you're not struggling
um I'm curious you you told us what you
made uh this month the previous month
and which kind of have down down the
pipe but what were your first six months
like
so month one I did about 1.5 million
dollars in deals
um and so what does that amount to
what's your net profit I made like 35
Grand in one month
yeah so what's been your worst month I
mean that's that's not necessarily
counting broker fees and stuff but sure
okay okay okay I'm with you so what
would be your net income after all fees
give me your worst month yeah so far
you there
well we had a good run with Landon well
let's keep talking about this because
we'll see if we can get them back let's
try to get him back but what I'm what
we're getting at and what I know what
I'm getting at is I want to see what the
track record has been with this because
if it's like hey I made thirty thousand
or you know now I made 32 but I was
making seven I was making five I was
making four I made ten you know if it's
been very sporadic and then all of a
sudden there's a jump off that's great
I'm happy for him I would want to know
more about it did you meet somebody what
was the connection like what has
happened that has made this explode
um in a good way and is that something
that's sustainable you know because
because having his wife uh decide that
she's gonna stay home that's a big you
know that's a big deal and to go from a
you know oh he's back Gregory
all right Landon sorry we uh what
happened you hit some turbulence I have
no it just said call failed I don't know
what happened that's all right so we're
just speculating over here about your
situation we're trying to define the
track record
to a mathematical equation if your
expenses are four thousand dollars and
your worst month was six thousand
dollars we can she can stay home
tomorrow
and if you can learn how to manage this
a regular income it's not going to be a
problem well our expense I mean we're in
baby step seven our house is paid for
and we don't have any debt okay so
security and we have about 70 grand in
our emergency fund okay um and so the
plan was to just take a salary out of
whatever commission so if I make 35
Grand in a month just take like a five
thousand dollar salary out of that and
then just continue to put the rest to
whatever we need to as far as an
emergency fund retirement whatever yeah
you guys are at the point where you just
build wealth and give yeah I mean the 15
and for retirement now you can do 25
plus you could save up in an index fund
and purchase some real estate and you
can have some real fun or give it
outrageously I love it definitely our
plan is just to save up and pay cash for
rental real estate and invest heavy and
give that's great yeah I'd say go for it
you're in a good position you've done
everything right and you have no reason
to fear an in a regular income very cool
he's not scared to work and and that
tells me no matter what happens yes it's
going to be okay if there's a bad month
he'll go out and make money elsewhere
worst case one day if his wife wants to
work she can go do that again for sure
inside the home that's right yeah you
can always go back if you want to very
very cool it's a big goal for a lot of
people though to stay at home it is and
you know I was thinking about this
earlier today before we even got on the
show I was sitting by myself thinking
about the fact that so many people call
in and they're trying to know am I to
the point where you know my wife can
stay home or if it's a stay-at-home dad
situation and I think that it is
something that a lot of people aspire to
and it's it's so hard sitting on this
end when you have to say no
if you do that you're gonna like your
finances are gonna suffer so much it's
better if you continue working it's
almost like taboo to tell someone you
know you're calling a financial show and
if it were us we'd keep working to pay
down that debt and it's like what you'd
rather me take time away from my
precious eight-month-old you know and
and people think that we're really
heartless yeah be heartless but at the
end of the day it's like no we want you
to have the best possible scenario and
this is not the case with Landon his
wife can stay home tomorrow probably
stayed home years ago absolutely but I
mean with a lot of folks it's like no
you might have to sacrifice a little on
the front end so that you can attain
that dream later on and sometimes you
have to say no well a lot of people call
into the show and a spouse already stays
home yep they have a huge pile of debt
they've got five kids and the household
income is like 35 Grand and we're going
this is a you're never going to be out
of debt you're always going to have
these money struggles if we don't make
some serious sacrifices so doing it the
right way the first time uh which is
usually the hard way is the best way for
peace and less stress that's right and
even though everybody you know your
friend's Circle or the folks on
Instagram might be doing it it doesn't
mean that you can afford to do it you
can do whatever you want to do but it
doesn't mean that you can afford to do
whatever you want to do ouch Jade you're
hurting your feelings out there already
oh I'm preaching a little bit this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsay show it's
Jade warshaw here joined by George camel
as my co-host also host of The Amazing
YouTube channel the George Campbell show
oh thank you yes we're having a good
time I I see that I'm having too much
fun I put on a temporary tattoo for a
video today if that tells you how much
fun we're having where is said tattoo
located George on my bicep if you can
even call it a bicep I don't know if I
can it's scientifically busting through
your shirt oh yeah I wear baggy shirts
just so I don't make anyone jealous like
John deloney I know we don't we feel
very insecure when we're next to you
George but you can go check that out we
got new episodes Monday Wednesdays and
Fridays and then smart money happy hour
yes our show with Rachel Cruz that drops
on Thursday so I almost have every day
of the week locked in yeah I love smart
money happy hour
um I listen to it on my long runs and
it's oh thank you it is it keeps me it
like entertained during my run so I'm
not keeps you distracted maybe I should
try that I should try running and then
listening to smart money happy yeah you
need something to distract you from the
pain and smart money happy hour does
just that
um something else here that's
um not painful but actually really great
is Austin one of our producers said you
guys need to check out this article and
I've actually seen this before it says
gen Z is ditching credit cards for cash
stuffing and a 90s throwback so it's not
just the fashion that's come back now
not just the jinko jeans it's also cash
stuffing I mean they're trying to make
it sound like this is like an ancient I
mean I guess it is pretty old but it
made me feel old when I read it he says
as well as flip phones look at this just
like flip phones micro mini skirts
popcorn tops I think I missed that Trend
lately what the heck is a popcorn top
what is that is that like I have to
Google that one later gen Z is bringing
they're bringing cash back yeah that's
what is this a staggering 69 of gen Z is
using cash more now than they did 12
months ago more than gen z Oh Gen X is
47 wow ooh that's crazy or Baby Boomers
37 so what are we attributing to this it
says cash or envelope stuffing is an old
school budgeting hack commonly touted by
renowned financial advisor Dave Ramsey a
big boss man and that is making a
Resurgence on social media as gen Z
struggles to get a grasp on finances
well you know I applaud them George
they're going we're so broke that we're
gonna stop using the credit cards and
resort to cash because that keeps us on
track right yeah usually you know we
read articles and we're going off in a
huff of smoke
proud of these people if if you realize
what you're doing has not been working
and if it takes you adopting apparently
an ancient form of money management
his feelings would be hurt that his 30
year old advice is now considered
ancient so if you don't know
nothing is what we're talking about here
is the envelope system that Dave made
popular back in the day where you
actually for your budget you say I've
got 300 bucks for groceries this month
I'm gonna withdraw 300 bucks from the
bank in cash put it in an envelope use
that when I shop when it's out it's out
and I gotta figure it out what a concept
and you know here's the thing about the
cash envelope system I love it my
husband and I use that a lot when we
were getting out of debt and sometimes I
get the question of like like how does
this work yeah there are categories that
work better with cash stuffing right
like you would hard to do with your
electric bill right the stuff that you
have to do that online payment you
wouldn't do it with that but things like
gas that's not where you groceries you
overspend on eating out groceries going
out and shopping at the mall whatever
that's right preach it and I'll just say
George I posted on social media the
other day about you know a lot of people
are like it's so hard for me jade to
stick to the budget what do you suggest
and I'm like when it comes to sticking
to the budget it's not always like sure
power right you've got to put these
habits in place that help you succeed
and so I always go to cash stuffing I'm
like put you the right amount of cash in
your wallet and not only that I'm going
to challenge somebody listening right
now take out the credit cards and take
out the debit card get rid of the
plastic out of your wallet you want it
you want to stick to your budget how bad
do you want it take that plastic out and
if you know hey I'm going to the grocery
store I I double dog dare you to just
take the 200 in Cold Hard Cash and see
what happens it's like one of those
cleanses where you take out like sugar
and alcohol for three weeks and you
realize how great you feel for the first
time in your life the same thing happens
financially when you go on putting the
cards away I want to feel the pain of
having to use the cash and when you do
that at the grocery store you're going
I'm going to switch to the generic brand
you know I'm gonna put that back that
was a snack yeah I don't actually need
that for sustenance yeah and I mean
think about it it happens all the time
you're like okay my budget is you know
200 and then inevitably at the cash
register it says 2046 60 63 and you're
like I'll just take out the debit card
and do the 463 but if all you have is
Cash you put the Pop-Tarts back that's
right and that's called delayed
gratification and discipline and
willpower and self-control things we
would all do better to have in today's
society so I'm proud of gen Z because
this is big uh a survey found that
nearly half of gen Z said they relied on
social media for financial advice the
most of any generation and a quarter of
them said they learned more about money
from content creators than school or
books so what happened here was a tick
tocker Financial influencer or
finfluencer which is somehow a word
Stephanie Garcia she's got over 300 000
followers is that she does weekly cash
stuffing videos is that baddies and
budgets
that might I don't know that might be
her because that is that's her yeah I've
seen that her content is really fun like
she makes it very very fun baddies and
buddies and she says when you leave
money in your account you swipe your
debit card you don't realize how much
money you're spending because it's not
something tangible at first I only
cashed out for my bills then that way I
knew that money I had left I could spend
because I would always overspend because
here's the thing people use the credit
card and they go well Jade I never pay a
diamond interest I still I'm good you
can't budget when you use a credit card
think about this you get the bill at the
end of the month that's right in one
lump sum you can't budget individually
to see if you're even on track or
overspending in a category you're living
in reverse
reverse you're living in hindsight going
hope I have enough money in the account
to cover the credit card bill that's not
a recipe for for wealth or financial
success not to mention a good point on
that George is a lot of people do get
caught up on the fact that oh I'm not
paying interest I pay it off every month
maybe you do but we know that the stat
the statistics do tell us that you are
spending at the very very least 12 to 15
more when you're you know using plastic
as opposed to cash and specifically when
you're using credit card so it's very uh
much worth thinking about that there uh
let's try to take a little call here
George we got some time let's see what
Jordan what Drew is talking about in
Boston hey that's your stomping ground
George Boston Massachusetts I was just
there Drew what's going on
uh good afternoon Jaden George it's it's
a privilege to be speaking with you
although I wish I wasn't
um but uh because of a situation not
because he doesn't want to talk to us
okay that's right exactly exactly uh
long story short I'm 33 years old I make
a little over a hundred thousand uh take
homes just roughly over 61k I have
somehow
um got into a position where I've got
over just over 76 000 worth of debt in
credit cards and personal loans I'm
getting married in November and I've got
zero dollars saved up and I'm just
thinking maybe I should take out a 401k
loan to pay off some of this debt and I
was just wondering what you're doing so
um
I I am we are going to talk about the
idea of a 401k loan in a second
but I'm going to challenge you big time
on the phrasing that you used about your
debt you said I somehow
somehow I'm not really sure what I did
somehow wandered into seventy six
thousand dollars of debt
and I want you to get real honest and be
like no I didn't just somehow wander
into it it didn't just lightning didn't
strike me and I ended up in debt I made
some decisions here like I made some
choices and now I have debt right
correct yeah I mean yeah I guess that
was poor wording I I definitely live
outside of my means and I'm trying to
get onto a budget I'm just I have been
having trouble sticking with it but I'm
at the point now where it's like uh this
I have to you know stick to this budget
good and so I totally recognize that I'm
just trying to figure out like if I
could take out this loan it's my kind of
my last resort I think it's not a real
solution it's a fake solution that puts
you further into debt and so the
solution we're gonna use is the one in
the mirror it's you it's your future
income it's selling stuff it's side
hustles it's living on less than you
make getting on a budget we're gonna
help we're gonna send you Financial
Peace University for one year and every
dollar premium but listen to 401K puts
your retirement savings at risk it robs
the future growth of that money you're
going to be stuck and tied to your
employer and you're gonna end up paying
taxes on those loan repayments twice so
it's like triple stupid
do not do this at all costs and you
don't have to you can't borrow your way
out of debt that's a fact you got to pay
your way out of debt this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
you are listening to the Ramsay show and
I'm your host Jade warshaw joined by my
other host George Campbell and uh George
this morning it was so cool because
right now we are in the midst of entree
Leadership Summit which is like a giant
event going down for Business Leaders
and it's been cool to like listen in on
these amazing Business Leaders give
these talks and encourage us and
challenge us and kick our butts did you
get to see any of it I didn't I've been
here working Jade but our leadership
team is up the hill at the events I know
I know but I've been jealous because we
had Ken Coleman speaks we got Dr Jordan
Peterson Willie Robertson Gladwell yeah
Dr John deloney will be speaking Friday
so it's a Powerhouse lineup and of
course Dave Ramsey of course speaking
every day but uh so I have a little bit
of fomo but I am excited because we're
going to be a part of an event this fall
called smart conference oh tell us more
well we had a wild one in October right
here in Nashville Tennessee but we are
headed to Chicago this September so if
you've never experienced smart
conference before let me tell you you
are missing out this is my favorite
event of the year it's our biggest event
of the year it's packed with inspiration
motivation information and we talk about
how to get control of your money
improving your mental health
strengthening relationships building a
successful career so whether you're in
baby step two you're just getting
started or you're in baby step seven you
followed this stuff for 10 15 years now
you're going to leave fired up and
smarter our next one is in Chicago this
fall with all the Ramsay personalities
Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz Dr John deloney
Jade warshaw Ken Coleman and myself
smart conference is now a weekend
September 15th and 16th we're going to
do a live recording of smart money happy
hour that the audience gets to be a part
of that's been my favorite part of the
event and right now the early bird
general admission ticket is just 79
bucks for a two-day event wow we have
some limited VIP tickets Platinum
tickets so do not wait to get yours
they'll always sell out VIP tickets
include a meet and greet with Rachel
John Jade Ken and me and one of our
favorite parts of the event is getting
to meet all the people out there that's
right yes love that part that's amazing
getting to hear their stories it's
different than just hearing them on the
phone so we love to celebrate your
success and it's a huge part of this
event so go to ramseysolutions.com
events get your tickets today and we
will see you at smart conference and 79
storage that's like a it's like a bad
meal at Applebee's that's true family of
four and you can have a two day I mean
you can't even go to a live event that's
a ticket fee yeah from Ticketmaster we
don't do that around here we run the
show like that's it's just flat out 79
bucks that's what I'm talking about well
I'll be there and I hope that I see you
there uh let's go to the phone lines
George let's do it we got Nona from
Auckland Eau Claire oh Claire my
favorite my favorite artist is from
there Bon Iver Justin Vernon no no knows
what's up how's it going Nona I've never
heard of them check them out
we're doing good I can I make a can I
have a moment of confession right here
uh George what did you call the music
group I always thought they were called
Bon Iver yeah and you heard everyone I'm
sorry a puppy's tail stopped wagging
when you said that I I'm sorry I usually
get it right okay it's a French word for
good winter it's a whole I'm not gonna
nerd out on indie folk right now but
sorry Nona forgive me I didn't know but
now we're here to help how can we help
um so I
have a question I
did a bit of a backstory behind it I'll
try and be brief
um so a long time ago we went through
the baby steps paid off all our debt
saved up money for a Don for our
emergency fund and then put it down
payment on a house and then I found out
I would we found out I was pregnant
um my daughter was born
um and that was kind of when everything
fell apart on us
um she was born with brain damage due to
oxygen health
and spend eight weeks in the NICU
um
fighting for her life and then
about every after she got home about
every eight weeks she would be
re-hospitalized with pneumonia due to
aspiration wow um
so shortly after her first birthday I
lost my job
um and it's just been kind of a struggle
um
so
hopefully we never went back into debt
that's great
um but we did it during our emergency
fund
um and now we've got uh like a whole
bunch of house like maintenance we need
to replace things and fix things that
we've just kind of been pushing off
um
and I'm just not sure how to get back on
track my husband makes about 50 000 a
year I've
picked up bookkeeping I picked up a side
job with lifeguarding and teaching
swimming lessons that's wonderful
um
so financially we're starting to get
back on tracks but I'm just having
trouble
staying focused and getting back on like
a budget and yeah look you've been
through you guys have been through a
storm and you're still it sounds like
you're still in it and you're still
fighting to kind of get your bearings
um I think when that happens it's very
easy to lose focus it's very because you
go into survival mode right you're just
like the last thing you're thinking
about is money you're thinking about
your child which you should be
um and what I want to say to you is man
just forgive yourself for whatever you
might be feeling like oh I messed up our
finances I messed up our money just let
that fall to the Wayside because now's
another day and today is another day to
pick it back up and go okay like what do
we need to do now to make sure we're in
the best possible position and it sounds
like you've already kind of started that
Journey Back which is great I applaud
you for that
um you're doing the bookkeeping you're
doing some other things what's that
bringing in for you right now
uh not a whole lot
500 a month okay
um and then between lifeguarding and
swimming lessons I'm expecting about
three another three hundred dollars a
week ish and that should just fill in
the gaps a little bit until my
bookkeeping until I can get a few more
clients that's wonderful
um so how can we help you how exactly
can we help you today
um well the the main question was
um I have we have to rebuild our
emergency fund and then we've also got
the maintenance on our house like we
need to replace a roof we need to Our
Deck is routed through
um any new tires for my car and I'm just
not sure what to tackle like how to go
about getting it all done if I should do
it like like in the baby's set like the
the that snowball and just like
I'd make a list by priority of this
cannot wait we've got to do this today
um and we've got to do this so get with
your husband and you guys just initially
just brainstorm all the things that you
feel like are weighing down on you like
that need maintenance make that list and
then go back through that list and
prioritize it by importance and then
start gathering information how much is
this honestly going to cost us what's
the cheapest we could do it for and at
this point it's one of those things
George where there's so many things
floating around in your brain it's just
giving you anxiety and if you can write
it down like actually grasp it from the
air and put hands around it and then go
okay it what's it gonna cost me to get
new tires it's going to be 600 okay and
really put
um just break it all down into little
bite-sized chunks where you have a daily
little to-do list today I'm gonna
research the contractors in the area and
get some quotes on the deck that's it
and then I'm gonna figure out when the
roof needs to be replaced if that's six
months from now let's figure out 10
grand divided by 6 months here's how
much we need to save each month and
start to make a plan for that create a
sinking fund in our budget and so once
you do that you put it on paper it makes
me feel better because I am I'm like no
no like all these things floating around
my head I need some semblance of process
and system and control and that helps
and and just understand you're not going
to be able to do it all at once and
that's okay and some of this stuff is
going to get done this year and some
stuff it might make wait till next year
but you both need to go into it with the
idea of and with the the boundary of we
are not going into debt and sometimes
you know those things sometimes it can
feel like just pounding on your door
like the big the big bad wolf and it can
feel like it's pressuring you to go into
debt and I'm telling you if you take
that off the table there's always going
to be a solution that you're going to
get creative and go okay okay you're
going to reach out to your community
you're going to find a friend who knows
a plumber who will do it for you you
know at cost you you're going to find
all those things so just be patient uh
make a plan and hey we're pulling for
you yeah you're not the person we're
here to beat up on and go what are you
doing you have been through it that's
right so if it takes you six months
longer than the average person that's
okay I know it's frustrating but this is
a very different Journey for you guys
and you're doing so so well you guys are
fighting you're scratching you're
clawing you're doing all the right
things and it feels like this is going
to be forever but it's not the stuff's
gonna get repaired the emergency fund
will be in place we're gonna get this
health situation figured out we're
pulling for you Nona that's so great we
love you Nona this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
what's going on everybody you are
listening to the Ramsay show I'm your
host today Jade warshaw and co-hosting
right next to me I can't believe it
George camel in the flesh you better
believe it believe that thank you George
for hosting with me today it's been fun
it's a pleasure um I learned that you
have a new tattoo on your arm I do have
a it's a temporary tattoo I want my mom
to know I don't have any tattoos mom
don't worry but I did it for YouTube I
did it for the likes you know go for the
story do it for this so you'll have to
tune into the YouTube channel to see
when that makes a cameo I want you to do
sparkly let me just put that out there
it is very sparkly I have so many
questions I want you to like rip it
America is not ready also we're airing
on TBN and that's a family friendly
Network so we want to keep it that way
Jade well George all you have to do is
flex your bicep and it will Rip right
out of your shirt even the idea of me
flexing a bicep is generous to call it
that but I appreciate that Jade well if
you are listening for the first time
time thank you for dealing with us we're
just shooting the breeze here but maybe
you've been listening for a little while
um a couple of weeks a couple of months
and you're like I really like this
Ramsay show but sometimes you guys say
things and I'm like what does that mean
I hear you guys talk about the baby
steps I hear you say funny phrases like
dead is dumb cash is king or beans and
rice rice and beans and I just I got the
fomo right I want to know more about
this if that's you and you want to take
a deeper dive into the Ramsay whole deal
whether it's the Ramsay show Ramsay baby
steps all of this go on to
ramseysolutions.com and all you have to
do is click that get started button and
we're just going to help you figure out
what's your best next step for your
financial Journey that's based on
exactly where you're at today and along
the way you are going to learn the lingo
you are going to become one of us a
Ramsay yet as somebody said the other
night join us no that's very weird we
are normal people not weird in that type
of way at all
um well maybe George is a little bit but
that's Ramsey's solutions.com and
remember click the get started
button and then you can do that all
right let's talk to William William is
in Chicago Illinois what's going on
William shy town
hey Jay uh George my question here is um
I'm
I want to know I'm struggling to budget
for um baby step six kind of getting a
good balance between enjoying life and
and
um completing baby step six I'm
currently on two but uh I will be able
to get through three four five in the
next month or so whoa wow is it like a
windfall what happened
I knew you would go there but yeah so I
got I I have 50k in liquid I got a
vehicle I'm gonna sell it's a toy car
it's got about
um I gotta I I have a car loan for it
it's 40K and it's worth about 80. wow so
um it's worth 80 I owe 40. so it's going
to give you what you need
yeah pay off my wife's student loans
um she's gonna be graduating so I think
that's what I will do with that money
since I'm kind of all in on the baby
steps now that'll take care of all the
debt um I've been saving 15 plus
throughout
um a couple years already before the
baby steps so about 225 on my 401k
already ding ding um
and I've been doing a little bit of
saving for the children's uh for the uh
college fund how many kids do you have
again okay
I have three now uh one is going to
college this year uh and that the other
one's going to college next year wow uh
my commitment to them was uh two-year
Community College I will pay for it love
that pocket cash flow it and then you
guys can work and and cash flow it
yourself come on William that's what I'm
talking about that's the move right
there I love it so what's your household
income
uh so average uh two 250 a year the
wife's gonna graduate so she'll she's
going to be a nurse practitioner she's
going to bring in some good cash
wonderful she said she's a nurse now so
she's bringing some some uh a decent
amount every year but she only works
part-time but she'll be able to go to
full time and that's great we're gonna
the goal is baby step six but again how
do I
how do I enjoy life right um if I am in
this decent I don't know if I am in a
decent situation I would just sometimes
I feel like I am with your income I'm
not with your income and the fact that
you're about to be basically through
baby steps two three you've already
started on four uh for all intents and
purposes but you're in great shape with
that income and you know we always say
that the first few baby steps are about
being super intense and going hard and
gazelle intents and rice and beans but
where you're going to is going to be way
more about intentionality I love that
you have a plan already in place for
baby step five which is paying for kids
college and then going into six it's
about looking at your margin I mean
you're going to continue to budget and
do all of those
um smart habits that you've put in place
but then you're going to look at your
margin at the end of the month and go
okay we've got x amount of dollars how
much do we want to put towards the
mortgage because we do need to put a
fair amount towards the mortgage and you
know work towards paying that off but
you know you you've we've done the work
so it's time to live a little as well
and so there is a balance there and it's
up to you and your wife really to decide
what that looks like is it a percentage
game where you go hey whatever the
margin is we're putting 40 to the mark
to the mortgage extra and then the other
60 we play with and we're doing this and
that with that it's really up to you how
you wanna I mean George how did you how
did you my wife and I were extra weird
so we went intense because we just felt
like it and we don't we didn't have kids
we had very little responsibility and so
we paid our mortgage off in 26 months we
also got a very reasonable modest home
modest mortgage so what's your mortgage
William
I'm on a 15-year uh more my my loan is
170 the whole house is worth 400. dude
you're gonna pay this thing off
legitimately I'm my guess is two and a
half three years yeah
and that's like you're still living life
I'm thinking but I I don't know if if
that that still be too aggressive or or
I mean can I throw something out there
to you William
can I can I just float something
um
this is this is Jade talking sometimes I
feel like when people don't have to have
much of a journey in the debt payoff
right they don't have to go through that
you know three years of intense like
paying it off right you might be more
likely to do that on the mortgage
no you'd be I have been the last year I
I mean I had a 401k loan I had okay you
know so I've been knocking them down I
mean I've had some good income so I've
been doing that for the last year and a
half right oh okay so you have been on
that on that tip okay here's what I like
Jade mentioned I just like having goals
say we want to we want to save ten
thousand for vacations I'm gonna create
a sinking fund in my budget and save up
ten thousand we want to upgrade our
clothing line item great let's upgrade
that and whatever's left we are going to
dedicate towards the mortgage so that
might be for you guys let's say you
bring 12 or 15K home a month we're gonna
dedicate six grand extra on top on the
mortgage and we're gonna make that auto
pay and that's going to be our goal and
if we can increase that at some point
that's cool but that at least we know is
gonna get the house paid off in three
years yep yeah the point is just being
intentional with whatever you decide
um like George said I love that idea of
the sinking funds but you know still
living some of your life too because the
the fact is you have done well you know
and we we don't want to take that part
away you know I think sometimes George
people think that we don't want you to
have fun with your money we just want
you to pay off debt and like keep your
head down and you know but in this case
William you you've done that you're
making a good income the fact that
you're calling it you know you've got a
plan for college you're doing all the
right things so yeah like George said
let's bring up the the vacation budget a
little bit let's bring up the clothing
budget a little bit or maybe to go out
to eat budget and in the midst of that
we can also pay a full extra payment on
the house or two full extra payment you
know whatever that looks like for you
and that's really really exciting so
very well done yeah that's a great goal
to have and most people pay off a
mortgage in 30 years if they're lucky if
you're following the Ramsay plan we
found that people actually pay their
mortgages off in about seven years
following the baby steps and our
millionaire study we found that
millionaires on average pay off their
homes in 10 years that's right so
anywhere between seven and ten years
you're doing really well if you beat
that you're just super weird and with
that kind of income those numbers and
the low mortgage High income that
thing's gonna get knocked out in a few
years even with vacations and Sport
there's only so much stuff money can buy
that's true I'm I like having Freedom uh
you know in that windshield yeah I love
not having a payment yeah and I think
you know what I was saying to him before
is there it's oh okay if you and your
spouse decide that you want to go hard
on paying off that that mortgage and
just being aggressive about it that's
your bag too like if mama needs a
pedicure get her the pedicure okay get
her the morning I can wait another day I
know right have fun live and give like
no one else that's baby step seven and
you'll be there in no time that is right
I love it well that does it for this
hour guys be sure to join us next time
on the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey what's up guys it's Jay if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and build
actual amazing relationships I am your
host Jade warshaw and I am joined by the
most incredible George camel now it's
just condescending Jake come on no one's
believing this I only speak the tooth
the truth George the the truth the whole
truth nothing but the truth that's what
we do on the show we tell you the truth
that's right we will so call in give us
your situation we will chop it up
amongst ourselves and we will come to
the most logical conclusion that is what
we do on this show and that's what we're
going to do right now with Benjamin from
Boston Massachusetts and by the way you
can call us at the number
888-825-5225 that is what Benjamin did
and here we are Benjamin what's going on
buddy
how you doing doing good how are you
I'm good I'm just uh I called to put in
a uh my situation to see what you guys
would uh instruct me to do and I'm
open-minded and I'll be very honest with
you guys and everything
um a year and a half back about a year
we were in a lease it was a 2023 Honda
uh Odyssey uh-huh we were paying 400 a
month for the lease and uh my wife got
hit with three of my kids in a car and
the car the car rolled over three times
now on the lease yeah annalize you have
to have uh full insurance there's no
going around it which I did okay I had
full insurance everything was uh done uh
thank God none of my kids were hurt my
wife heard her wrist pretty bad
oh so thank God it wasn't worse my
goodness that sounds terrible when when
I got the phone call believe me as a
father my my heart dropped all the way
down like I thought I thought my
brother-in-law was lying to me at first
and nobody was hurt because you know how
to try to comfort you so it was very
emotional for me but thank goodness
yeah yeah and nobody was hurt but the
insurance
left the singing because the car was
totaled they said we're not covering it
uh my wife ended up getting sued for
seven thousand dollars
and we were left with all the medical
bills now I was kind of in the process
was where I was already reading and my
sister was teaching me about Dave Ramsey
and all the the breakthroughs and
everything like that because my sister
did this program and she succeeded she
paid off her house they have no bills
they're doing really good with
everything so they were teaching me some
stuff unfortunately I was at the
beginning of all this and now I was
stuck with an 80
000 bill that you know what I mean they
want you to pay for the card that you
don't even have and everything like that
so when you try to reach to a lawyer
everybody's pushing you away no I don't
want to deal with you if you don't have
money
so it was can I ask some questions about
your yeah so I mean of course you have
to have coverage but did you I mean
what was your coverage at the time
because it it just by you saying it
sounds like your insurance company they
just left you hanging yeah yeah so the
problem was this my wife was in the
process of uh getting her our license or
Michigan license at that time because we
were in Michigan
and she drove somewhere because of an
emergency we were we were done with this
apartment we really really needed to get
out to another apartment this was during
covid I think 2020. or 2021 I think 2021
it was and uh we really needed to look
for a place and I was working at the
time
uh unfortunately the place where I was
working at was really withholding money
from us like I I do construction and the
guy was not Benjamin what's that got to
do with the one sentence tell me why the
insurance didn't cover the car okay
cover the cost is because they said she
was not on it
she was uninsured at the time she was
driving this vehicle yeah okay he was
not on the policy according to them it
was just you
yes but I asked them the cart is in my
name not in my wife's name so I asked
them this question I asked them wait a
second so if my dad comes over and takes
the car you're telling me I have to call
you guys to put them on insurance
technically
um I know when I came here I borrowed my
dad's car as a secondary vehicle and I
had to add myself and any other drivers
I either had either had to add his car
to my policy or I had to add myself to
my dad's policy because at the end of
the day when you're insuring your
vehicle you're insuring your your
vehicle with yourself in those drivers
it's not necessarily it's not
necessarily saying that anybody can
drive this car anytime and they'll be
insured
um so you know you those are
this is a really really hard lesson to
learn this is a really yeah anyone who
drives your car on a regular basis who
lives in your household has got to be on
your insurance that includes the kids
she didn't drive it on a regular basis
that was no problem she never drove it
is because I owned the car and she
wasn't driving this was the only I think
twice that she ever drove it twice so
have you been able to speak with have
you been able to speak with a lawyer
because at the end of the day with this
you're gonna need to lawyer up I tried
and they kind of push you away when you
don't have the money unfortunately a lot
of times they don't want to speak to you
when you don't have the money to well
you wouldn't do anything about it you
would I mean is it about the money or is
it the fact that they don't think you
have a case here
so every one of them that I've ever
reached to they said okay let me look
into it and then they never get back
it's because they don't think you have a
case well let's pretend like this is not
going to pan out and you're going to owe
this money what is the plan to pay this
off
my plan was to honestly the only thing
that I can do is uh file for bankruptcy
no no that's not over seven thousand
dollars no it's eighty thousand whether
that's the medical bills
medical bills the lawsuit the car and uh
I'm adding uh a credit card debt in
there too how much is a credit card debt
credit card debt is about fifteen
thousand okay what's your income right
now and you and your wife combined
okay so just just so you know my income
right now is very it could be this in
one month it could be well it's in
another month in Massachusetts and I'm
trying to start something with my
brother-in-law right now in business but
right okay hold it hold it hold it hold
it I'm gonna give you I'm gonna give you
the the blueprint right here you need a
job today you need it I get wanting to
start a business but we need to make
money two day full-time 40 plus hours a
week and keep building the thing with
your brother-in-law or your family
member on the side if wife is able to
work wife needs to work if she's taking
care of kids at the home she's still got
to find a way to pick up some part-time
hours here or there we're going to pay
off this debt we're going to keep a
thousand dollars aside as just a little
savings little something there and we're
gonna put any and all money into this
debt snowball and pay off this debt
you're gonna call up all of those
medical bills and you're going to try to
settle you're going to try to make a
deal for less and tell them I don't have
any money this is what I can give you
and try to make deals on those and we're
going to work the debt snowball listing
the stuff smallest to largest and we're
gonna go after it we got it we gotta
change this Benjamin we can't we can't
try to you know it's fine to try to
wiggle out of it but sometimes you can't
wiggle out of it and if your wife was
uncovered you have got some debt to take
care of and I'm sorry that you're going
through this you guys learned a really
tough lesson in all of this and
unfortunately there is a huge uh burden
to pay because of it man
that's tough but bankruptcy is not your
next option that's right you can climb
out of this thing it's not going to be
fun but you'll get out no more loans no
more leases no more credit cards cut
them up people pay off 80k every day you
can do it too this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
hey what's up guys you're listening to
the Ramsey Show I'm your host Jake
warshaw joined by one of my favorite
co-hosts of all time George camel
too kind you're welcome and I want to
tell you guys so earlier today I was up
on the hill where our Event Center is
and I was listening to a live stream of
our entree Leadership Summit event
that's going on it's Business Leaders
it's absolutely incredible but one of
the speakers was talking about the two
most important words in business which
are
drum roll please thank you
thank you I tried I know it was it was
like more like raindrops outside drummer
that's all right the words are thank you
and I thought man that's so true he was
like if you can say thank you as often
as possible when you truly mean it it
goes so far and I was thinking about
that man thank you to our listeners the
folks that listened to the show that
download this podcast that log on to
YouTube and because you know a lot of
people George they just put YouTube on
them in the background and it's how they
watch TV these days these kids and also
younger and middle-aged adults as well
but my point here as I'm rambling on is
if it wasn't for you guys listening to
the show me and all George here we
wouldn't have a job on the radio it's
not as much that's right and so we're so
appreciative of you guys listening to
the show maybe you've just been
listening for a couple of weeks or maybe
you're one of our long time loyal
listeners he's been listening five to
ten years thank you so much for tuning
in and let me tell you if this show has
helped you in any way if it has impacted
you if you've learned a little something
or you just find it entertaining tell
somebody share it with a friend hit the
like button hit the Subscribe button uh
pop on Instagram and put it in your
shares or send somebody a text or leave
a comment we just so so appreciate
um your support we so so appreciate that
you would trust us enough to speak into
really what's one of the most important
and also very private areas of people's
life their finances I talk about almost
anything before money look folks will
call in and talk to us about their
finances more than they might talk to
their significant other about it that is
very true you know so just please share
the wealth and we don't take that
lightly so I want to thank you guys I
know George feels the same way I know
everybody here feels the same way you
guys are what keeps this ship running
with that let's go to Michael in Houston
Texas what's going on Michael
um hey thank you for taking my call no
worries how can we help
um so right now I am in a really good
financial situation
um so right now I'm currently in my
second year of undergrad at Texas A M
and all my colleges paid for yes heck
yeah
so I'm not paying women board I'm not
paying tuition I am paying nothing how'd
that happen
um so right now I'm currently a Cadet at
Texas A M cool
so I'm planning to go Air Force upon um
commissioning I graduate um at a m and
um it's just that I have at least twelve
thousand dollars to um set aside for
um investing saving it's just
I don't think I should just leave that
money here but a part of me knows I
could do that so you have twelve
thousand dollars to your name liquid
cash and you're going should I be doing
something different with this than
letting it sit
exactly I'm guessing that's your
emergency fund obviously you don't have
a lot of expenses right now while in
school
but is that fair to say
yes sir okay so if I'm in your shoes
that's a great base Foundation I'm gonna
leave that in a high-yield savings
account and anything beyond that that
you save we can start using towards some
other goals like are you gonna need a
car one day are you gonna need to save
up for a home one day maybe we do start
you know funding a Roth IRA if we've got
some earned income
okay so do you have future income as
well while in school
like on future income are you working at
all
well right now I'm taking a break but I
am planning to work some internships
okay so I would leave that money alone I
know it's very tempting to go like I
could turn this into fifteen thousand or
Twenty Thousand but you also run the
risk of turning it into zero if you do
something stupid or risky and the fact
that you're not bringing in a steady
income right now it's just good to have
I mean in most situations we'd say three
to six months you're a little younger
and you're still in school but I think
with your situation it's good to have
that there
um you have a car
no sir okay
so you're just kind of uh Meandering
around campus right now that's nice yeah
that's that life
during life yeah yeah I feel that no
respect sponsor you know just being on
campus was a different time so take
advantage of this because you don't have
a steady earned income I don't want you
to go invest this money and all of a
sudden one thing pops up and you can't
pay for it yeah because whenever we're
gonna put our money and Investments
we're thinking hey five plus you know
five years and Beyond it's not a
short-term deal you've got two years of
college left so at the very least oh
three years so still at the very least
in three years you might want to get
your hands on some of that money for
some of the things that George was
talking about so for that reason I would
you know do it what George Campbell said
but if you can if you can keep this up
you graduate debt free with money in the
bank you are doing better than 99.9
percent okay of Americans and graduates
so we're proud of you man and thank you
for your for your service as well yes
love that great call thanks for the call
Michael
um I love when people are just doing
right that's great
we've had some tough calls today people
are in some real dark sad situations and
so you know it's a little upper that's
to get someone who's like hey I've got
money in the bank we're like whoa all
right let's celebrate with you that's
great well speaking of wins George
a win that we can talk about uh it says
Turbo Tax is sending out checks to 4.4
million customers as part of 141 million
dollar settlement now before you start
getting
people's panties and a lot about this
like oh 141 million let's just be real
about this it says customer is affected
by the settlement will receive an email
about the settlement and checks will
automatically be mailed throughout this
month most customers will get about
thirty dollars and some customers that
use Turbo Tax for three consecutive
years might get 85 dollars
winner winner chicken dinner that's all
you can get with that 30 bucks is a
chicken dinner at this point I don't
know no I don't even think you can get
if it's a family of four you ain't
getting a chicken dinner at Chick-fil-A
so you're probably wondering why why are
they doing this why do they owe so much
money yeah tell us well they steered
millions of low-income Americans away
from free tax filing services and
tricked them and then ended up charging
them and so we've been talking about
this Jade for years now I actually
released uh with another podcast I did
here on the Ramsey Network called the
fine print one of our first episodes was
all about Turbo Tax and it was called
how Turbo Tax is screwing you I remember
in March of 2021 I was here to warn
everyone James I was out here on the
street corner going guys don't use Turbo
Tax they're out to get you they're slimy
and here we are today with 141 million
dollar settlement do I take credit no
well does it make me feel pretty good
yes you were the first to report on it
George and let's let's be honest it says
Turbo Tax is predatory and deceptive
marketing and I agree with that cheated
millions of low-income Americans who
were just trying to fulfill their legal
duties to file taxes that's what a New
York attorney general said about it in a
press release she said today we are
writing that wrong and putting the money
back into the pockets of hard-working
taxpayers who should have never paid to
file their taxes so we remember those
that ad campaign they were running
everywhere and it was like free free
free all they said was free and then
people went to go find this free and
they couldn't find it they talked it
away on the website deep in a corner and
they ended up paying as a part of that
and not only that but in the podcast we
unpack their shareholder presentation
which by the way that's all they care
about not you the customer the
shareholders and they have this huge
strategy because Intuit is the company
that owns Turbo Tax of course and they
have this huge strategy to push debt
products towards the tax consumers all
of the people who use their different
products and so personal loans credit
cards they're in they're getting into
the debt business because guess what
that's where the profits are for these
companies these Financial companies
they're out there to make profit and
debt is a huge way they do that so when
you use Turbo Tax what they're doing is
collecting all your data to then sell
you on debt down the line so what you're
saying is when it comes to debt into it
wants you to get into it oh that was
good come on I got it that's a mic drop
right there come on guys where's the
hi-hat when you need man and by the way
if you have not listened to the fine
print podcast this is your we're putting
you on notice the fine print it's so
good it was a limited series we did and
it's I think there's like a 10 episodes
or so you can go check it out wherever
you listen to podcasts or on YouTube
we've got it streaming over there as
well but I just want to help people
avoid all these traps that are out there
and I can't keep up Jade everywhere you
turn it's like another Financial trap
another Financial trap it is exhausting
but it is worth it to save one person
from getting screwed by one of these
slimy companies that's right and I quote
the notorious George camel if you fall
for the trends
you fall for the traps there you go love
it George we did some mic drop moments
this hour magic this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
all right what's going on everybody this
is the Ramsay show I'm your host Jade
warshaw joined to my right by one of my
favorite just the good human being
people think I'm paying you at this
point Jade to just say nice things no
clear the air I have not received any
payments
um or under the table to compliment said
George Campbell yep he is truly a
wonderful human being and I feel sorry
for anybody who doesn't know him
personally all right wow there you go
that'll do it that'll do it I gotta
really do it I'm I'm driving with you
tomorrow so I'll return the favor I'll
say nice things about you okay it's
almost like those two dollars you paid
me are are worth it all right we got Joe
and Chattanooga what's going on Joe how
can we help today
hi George thanks for taking my question
today
sure how can we help
so I'll give you a little background and
then I'll ask a question
um but I'm recently divorced I have
three kids I share custody with them 50
50.
um my wife and I my we were debt free
including the house
um as of last May 2022 and then through
the divorce
um which was Final last month May
um I refinanced the house rather than
than us agreeing to sell it and I
refinanced it to reduce the
the change impact that the kids are
going to experience through all of this
so my question is should I sell or
downsize to be debt free again and if so
when
so what is now on the mortgage
uh 260. okay and this is just your
income now are you able to afford that
mortgage payment
yes
um but there's not a lot of margin there
you know I I what's your take on pay
versus the mortgage payment
um I have about margin of fifteen
hundred a month
but that's without contributing to 401K
um and the kids education and pain early
on the house
so what percentage of the of your take
on pay is this mortgage is it 30 40 50
no no it's it's like 24 25. okay right
on the line so this is reasonable
yeah but it's a 30-year it's not all it
doesn't align with with what
um what I'm trying to get at is this on
fire is this like we need to sell this
house tomorrow and it doesn't sound like
that's the case it's not on fire it's
just you know
my like would work so hard to get to the
debt free so it's frustrating because
you feel like you move backwards
yeah and and I still want to be able to
give the kids that life that I've been
working so hard for
um we have been working so hard for and
I feel like it's it may not be I don't
know fair is the right word but fair to
them well what the kids want is you guys
so all the stuff and the luxuries and we
were going to take them to Disney
we have to have a new picture of what
this life's going to look like and the
best thing you can do is give them
quality time and connection and the best
thing about that is it doesn't cost you
much you can have incredible experiences
and make the memories and you still have
1500 bucks so if you invested 15 of your
income and we set aside a little bit for
college we set aside a little bit for
paying extra on the mortgage how much
would you have left
uh so that would be
you solve a few hundred bucks
no just to reach the 15 it would be more
than the fifteen hundred dollars that
doesn't make sense mathematically
well
I'm about one I'm about 130.
okay so that would be 1950 a year
um and 1500 is 18 000 a year so
I wouldn't be a little short hey let me
ask you let me while George does a
little calculation there let me ask you
just a side question about like a little
emotional side of this
is do you enjoy being in the house
anymore
because I feel like you're like man we
were so far ahead we are our debt was
paid off now not only are you dealing
with this divorce but now you're back in
the house that was previously paid for
you know what I mean you're back in this
situation that's like so I just want to
know how you feel about that
um is that is that underneath this or is
it truly just well it's too much of my
take-home pay
It's a combination of both you know I I
still want to be
obviously this was our home for the last
six years so
um that's that's challenging to come
here every day and and be here
um and and then you've got the other the
other side where you know we did work so
hard to to get there
um
but I'm not
I I stayed in the house for the for the
kids I took a step like a huge step back
in my career for the kids so I could
have that connection have that quality
time with them to reduce all of this
this horrible impact that they're going
to experience if you did downsize what
would that look like can you paint that
picture for us right quick
yeah so I what I've been looking at are
these they've got like townhouses here
in Chattanooga and you I could downsize
to one maybe 1500 square feet and I
could
um effectively be debt free I could take
the equity from this house almost and
and pay cash for one of these town homes
and and to me I don't know if that that
makes sense or not financially
um just to sort of get uh I don't know
if it makes sense I don't know I mean I
love the idea getting back to death free
or not I love the idea of being debt
free I love the idea of a paid off home
residence
um I do like that I just want to make
sure that I kind of wanted to see all
sides of it what's the reasoning behind
it what you know does it work for the
kids you've got them 50 50 of the time
when they come if they were to come to
this townhouse would it be an
environment that they that you feel like
this is the right environment for them
as opposed to like a small apartment
where it's like this this is single dad
now he's got this apartment and the kids
feel weird so I just kind of wanted to
hear the other side of it um George what
are your thoughts because that doesn't
bother me downsizing I think doing it
for the right reasons and it will help
you become debt free allow you to invest
and put away money for college uh not
having to worry about that mortgage you
just refined so you paid the closing
costs so it hurts a little bit because
you're kind of paying the tax on that of
going I just paid all these closing
costs now I got to do this whole process
again yeah realtor fees pay more realtor
fees with the buying of the new place so
that's the only pain of this and moving
all three kids and that's a it's a big
change for them like you mentioned yeah
I kind of I do kind of wonder about that
how come in the process did you guys not
just decide hey we're going to sell you
know as part of the divorce we're going
to get rid of the house and then go
through it from there what kind of made
you
go back you know I don't know that's it
was just it was just my consideration
for the the kids
there's already so much change I was
trying to create a predictable State I
get it and supportive environment for
them like that's what I'm trying to
that's what I'm trying to create and to
your point Jade I don't want to move
into a small little place where the kids
come and it's kind of weird because they
got a single bad now that has my little
place no I like your idea for that
perspective I I I'll be honest with you
I don't I'm not mad at your town home
idea I like that you're going from
ownership to ownership you know if you
were like I just gonna take this money
out and get an apartment because I think
that we know that home ownership is such
a big part in wealth building so I do
like that you're going from ownership to
ownership which is good I like the fact
that you want to be debt free and you
don't want to take those steps backwards
I think this is one of those things
where you're just gonna have to take a
long look in the mirror and ask yourself
what's the best move the the house right
now you know you and Matthew you and
George went through the math it sounds
like you can't afford it so it's not
none of these are a bad choice it's just
yeah there's more numbers here that I'm
I feel like we need to dig into because
the mortgage is 24 but you can't invest
the 15 so where's all the other money
going is there is there pieces of you
know child support or animal alimony
here yeah no there there's child support
and if I can give you the number but
that's 750 and then um also contribute
to an HSA
um that we jointly use to share the the
medical expense for the children got it
okay so I would dig into the budget
first and see can we make this work but
if you're unable to invest 15 with these
current numbers and it's not going to
change in the foreseeable future I would
plan on downsizing the next six months
to a year in order to create that margin
I think you you'll feel the peace the
kids will adjust but their their picture
of their world is already shattered and
the home is just a piece of that and so
kids are resilient they will adapt and
you guys be in there and you sound like
they have great parents which is a huge
piece of this equation oh yeah yeah we
are
we're a budget is there any way that you
can make this work if not there's
nothing wrong with downsizing and
getting to a better Financial footing so
that you can accomplish the things that
you want to do and that you need to do
both for yourself and for your family
all right stick it out Joe this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey what's up guys this is the Ramsey
Show I'm your host Jade warshaw joined
by George Campbell to my right just your
everyday George camel nothing nothing
special nothing special
there we go that's more like it that's a
little bit of a long-running joke George
doesn't like it when I hype him up well
and people think me and Dr John deloney
have some massive beef because you know
John's awkward and weird and he'll make
cut you off you know so we like to joke
that Jon hates me but really he loves he
doesn't he loves me deeply we actually
are all friends that's really fun about
this job that is actually like the
people I work with so which is a good
reminder uh we're hiring so you can
check out all the open jobs at
ramseysolutions.com careers and uh hang
out with with Jade and I true that true
that that's right it was in the hallways
yes say hi in the hallways and speaking
of things going on here at Ramsay
Solutions uh we all have people who are
tuning in to every single episode of the
Ramsey Show I was one of those people
and they know all the stuff that we
teach about money and somehow they still
feel stressed and stuck so what can we
do why because knowing what we do with
our money isn't just the problem it's
actually doing it right you can listen
to the stuff all day long but until you
actually do it you'll feel no movement
we know that personal finance is 80
Behavior it's only 20 head knowledge
think about that for a moment and The
Proven way to change your behavior with
money is by taking the Financial Peace
University class y'all I can go on all
day about FPU I love it this class is is
the difference between trying to get in
shape on your own versus hiring a
personal trainer I love that you'll have
a coordinator holding you accountable
and the other people in the class
pushing you and cheering you on that's
why this class has worked for millions
and I'm one of those people by the way
Financial Peace University those
principles rock my world and after nine
weeks you will never handle your money
the same way again yes facts you will
make progress faster than ever you'll
make progress instead of excuses don't
just listen to the show commit to doing
what it takes to win join a financial
piece university class at Ramsey
Solutions today that's
ramseysolutions.com FPU to join and let
me just say right now the personality is
myself George John Rachel Eddie Ken Ken
I would never leave out Ken I know we
want to make sure actually I almost did
it by accident
um we're all hosting FPU classes
Financial Peace University we are being
we are your personal trainer we are the
one
I've always wanted to be a personal
trainer didn't think anyone would hire
me this is your chance for your money
you're the Hulk when it comes to money
that's right George's Hulk status and
you need that you need that kick in the
pants and once you sign up it gives you
the the
umph you need to push and go forward
um James Clear have you read the book
Atomic habits oh yeah James Clear talks
about the difference between motion and
action and I love that and a lot of
times we're doing a bunch of motion
surrounding our money but we're not
doing the actions so now is your chance
to put in the action work to actually do
something about it right and we're
getting our Behavior right so we can
actually change things and I always say
if uh Behavior if action is the car
behavior is driving oh I like that you
know I love a car analogy yeah put that
in your pipe and appreciate that I'm
excited my class it's too late to join
Jade's class because you're in the
middle of it you're gonna think of it
almost done but it starts June 20th so
if you want to join me virtually you can
do that at fpu.com but honestly whatever
you can do with your schedule go join
any class across the country we have
amazing coordinators who are leading
classes all over right there in your
neighborhood and it is so worth it to do
to commit to this for a few weeks to
change your life but let it be known if
I could join any class it would be
George Campbell's class and with that
we're going to Caitlyn and Charlotte
North Carolina what's going on Caitlyn
hi guys hey how are you
good so a year and a half ago my husband
and I bought a home and it was a
complete Fixer-Upper
um it took us about seven months to
renovate it in the meantime we lived
with my parents and we had two kids at
the time and in the middle of it I had
another baby and it was crazy but
um we ended up going about 45
000 over our original budget
um which was kind of not our fault
because once we got into things we
realized oh wow this needs to be done
this needs to be done and it just added
up really quickly so here we are a year
later and we are still about 40 40 000
45 000 in debt from this house and we're
kind of like we don't even know like a
month to month is just really hard so
yeah we're trying to figure out where do
we even begin like we do have at the end
so do we sell it do we like what do we
do possibly before we get into this
because you you clicked if I had an
invisible button if I had an invisible
button Caitlyn you you accidentally
pushed it because whenever people say
somehow we ended up in debt and they
kind of make it seem like they they had
no hand in it it just kidnapped them in
the night and you know did that and I
want you to know you know like let's be
real about that for a minute like hey we
just were like let's go on and do it we
if we need to do this now let's go on
and pay the money we'll go ahead and go
in debt to do it so it's such a big part
of going forward with what George is
going to explain to you next the first
part of that is going hey like I this
didn't happen to me I made some choices
I don't like those choices and we know
yeah right and that's what we're trying
to fix good let it be a lesson everyone
listening who thinks I'm going to be the
next chip and Joe and buy the next
Fixer-Upper and it's all going to go
perfectly and under budget and they're
gonna put us on the TV this is reality
yeah yeah this is reality so let's walk
through these numbers a little bit
what's the income looking like right now
um we make about 65 000 to 70 a year
okay is that with both of you working
outside the home
yeah so my husband is in the ministry
and I am like a self-taught photographer
cool okay so how much is
home with my kids okay how's that um
income spread out you versus him
um so he makes 50. and I I'm just trying
to like bust it and make as much as I
can great all right and what kind of
debt is this did you put it on a
personal loan a credit card
um okay so you probably won't like this
either
um we ended up using our paid off
vehicle as collateral and got alone from
that so that was that one is currently
000 then we have the rest of it on
credit cards okay
so
do you have any money set aside anywhere
else like do you have savings anywhere
that we should know about any liquid
cash
nope so we're kind of starting from like
baby step one because we've just kind of
been trying to strive month to month got
it okay well that that have the van at
least what's the van worth it's in
um we could sell it for about 17.5 or so
so we would still owe about 2 000 so we
could you know pay that off but you know
that that's kind of what my question is
like where do we even start like do we
keep it until we have the cash to pay
for yeah you can do that the other
option which I like you saving up cash
as the first option the other option is
you go to your local credit union and
you get the differences alone plus a
little bit to get you a beater car and
you can do it that way okay how quick
could you get okay 2 000 plus a little
bit more to buy a beater
um oh I did not sorry I meant to say
also we have another vehicle too that's
fine do you not need the van at all
could you get by with one car well
well what we were going to try to do
our original pin I guess was sell the
van keep the car trying to just pay the
car off through the debt snowball and
just use the one vehicle for now okay
I'm not mad at that that works that
works yeah I'm prone to saving up the
the difference as opposed to getting a
loan because I feel like you could do it
fairly quickly and then that's just
going to be clean like that and it gives
you some skin in the game because right
now we need some Behavior change more
than we need a mathematical equation
and so there needs to be some rice
yeah that's that's where we're at now so
that's we're just kind of over it and
we'd like to you know survive month to
month and we just feel like we're not
but my other question was should I
should I try to get another job should I
keep doing what I'm doing are you able
to do that with the kids situation
um
they're four two in one so it's kind of
hard but I mean look if you're able to
if you're able and willing to do
whatever it takes to increase your
income it's only going to help you at
this point and this is not a forever
situation right we're just doing this
we're kicking it we're busting it we're
doing whatever we have to do to get out
of this debt you're selling the vehicle
the rest is rolling into the debt
snowball and if you can make more money
to help that go faster more power to you
all right very good that does it for
this hour of the show be sure to join us
next time and remember when it comes to
changing your life and your money you
can tell me that you won't do it but
please don't tell me that you can't
because I already know With God all
things are possible this is the Ramsay
show
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsaysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships not to be confused George
with unactual we want the real thing
here isn't that all of social media of
course you're right about that
man I'm your host Jade warshaw and of
course joined to my right by the Six
Million Dollar Man George camel now
we're just straight up lying to the
people The Bionic Man hey I'll take it
yes that's right I love to find new ways
to introduce George so that people
really see him in the Grandeur that he
didn't I always wait with baited breaths
to see what adjective you'll use today I
actually looked that one up ahead of
time the Six Million Dollar Man
um give us a call the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and of course we want to talk to you
about your life your money what's going
on in your world what is going on in
your current situation uh nothing's off
limits as far as it comes to money right
give us a call let's talk about it
um let's go to Ben he's in Salt Lake
City Utah what's going on Ben
hello hey what's up
hey I uh just had a question about our
rental situation my wife and I are
living in Utah of course and we
currently are renting
um basically a suite where we're
watching my wife's grandpa's house okay
we were renting from him for really
cheap and it seemed like a sweet gig
until they uh they informed us that the
HOA was 55 plus and previously they
hadn't said there would be any issues
with us living there but now they're
kicking us out in about a month or two
the the curmudgeons on the HOA right
you guys I said I don't like these young
whipper snappers around here yeah right
we're throwing mad parties and they uh
yeah just smiling and waving at all the
all the people who want to grind up oh
man
what's this mean for you because if you
are breaking the HOA guidelines I mean
they do have the if it is what you say
it is they do have the right to did you
have anything in writing saying you
could live there and for how long
no to be honest I don't I don't believe
there's anything like that weird
um we were just told by our grandpa and
um that he had talked to them in that
um everyone he had spoken to had shown
that there won't be any problem with it
but I don't think there's anything in
writing we're planning on moving it's
just now a question of whether we should
rent or buy and it's just I can't figure
out which would be a better solution so
we're hoping to run it by you how much
time are they giving you before you have
to vacate the premises
so they told us we have to have
something figured out which is kind of
vague they told us we have to have
something figured out by the start of
July like July 8th that was a that's no
time wow they these These Old Friends
ain't playing so what's your financial
situation do you guys have any debt do
you have any savings
right so right now we we're making about
50 to 52 000 a year we have
um
let's see down payment of 30 000 or 25
000 saved up as well as emergency
Savings of
um above 8 000 it's roughly five months
of savings
um
right which is very minimal yes right so
we'll have to increase that and use some
of the down payment funds to cover the
emergency fund so let's call it 25k for
the down payment the rest is emergency
fund and you have no debt
yes okay
what are the prices in that area I
imagine uh are you in the Salt Lake City
area
so a little bit north of Salt Lake is uh
kind of what we're looking at late in
Ogden somewhere around there so it's
generally we're not seeing anything in
the housing market for less than
um 300 or 250 000
um and it starts getting pretty rough in
that range and then on top of that the
renting Market we're not seeing anything
comfortable we checked out some
apartments around here yeah not seeing
anything we'd feel comfortable with
below 1300. are you guys both working
full-time
I'm working full-time and in school but
schools being covered by FAFSA my wife
is working part-time and watching her
brother her special needs brother on the
side
I'm wondering if we can increase the
income if you're going to be you have
increased expenses coming up whether
it's rent or mortgage so that needs to
be part of the picture and so I don't
know who it sounds like that would be on
you to increase the income with her
obligations currently yeah but you're
also in school which makes it tough how
much longer do you have in school
um I think another year or two
um I was looking at graduating winter
okay so at the end of the day when you
do purchase the house we want to make
sure that it's something that you can
enjoy that is not setting you back that
you're not house poor and so we want to
make sure whenever you do buy that
you're able to put the right amount of
down payment on something that's a
15-year fixed rate mortgage right and we
don't want the payment to be any more
than 25 of your take-home pay that's
taxes HOA fees insurances all that
factored in right so that's what we're
aiming for so at this point it's really
just you guys getting out there and
seeing what you like what you don't like
what you think you can afford and really
putting a timeline on yourselves because
it's not to say that you have to move
directly into a house right now if
you're not ready then it's not the right
time
um and in your situation there's no
shame in renting let me just I mean
renting sounds like honestly at this
point it might be the move until you can
save up for some more money and keep
looking in different areas I mean
um when it comes to safety I want you
guys to live someplace safe but this is
the point of renting is to be able to
save up this is like Dave says it's
camping right it's this is not the life
of luxury in your rental it's it's to
get you somewhere it's a vehicle to get
you where you want to go ultimately
which is being a homeowner so there's
something to be said for that right
George yeah what's your take-home pay
right now oh he's gone sorry about that
George well I'm looking at the numbers
here on our mortgage calculator and I'm
going all right if they put even 90
grand down on a 300 000 house that
payment's gonna be you know 2100 bucks
yeah and so your take-home pay has got
to be close to eight grand at that point
yeah so that worries me because they
said they're making 50. it tells me
they're just not ready to be homeowners
and that's okay yeah it tells me all
right there's some things we can do now
number one we need to wait and save up
more number two we need to get our
income up yeah and so if we get our
income up to 75 and put that extra 25
towards the down payment yeah we're
cooking with gas because otherwise it's
gonna be a slog to try to save up three
five grand a year towards that payment
home prices keep going up it feels
impossible so if you're going to live in
a high cost of living area you got to
have a high income to go along with that
and that's just math that's not me
trying to be mean until you've got to
move but you might have to move further
out and and again we go back and we've
talked about this before right now and
at all times there's these things that
we want in life right we we want to be
the stay-at-home parent we want to
pursue home ownership there are these uh
milestones in life that we all want to
achieve and that's perfectly fine but
you have to be able to afford it yeah
right people say all the time when's the
best time to buy a house is it when the
market is like this is it when interest
rates are like this no it's when you can
afford it and that's the best time
everybody has a different definition of
a Ford and some people's definition is
it's okay if I can't put food on the
table as long as I live in this box that
I kind of own yikes recipe for disaster
yeah you want the home to be a blessing
and not a burden yeah that's exactly
right and if Ben follows the advice that
George Campbell is so beautifully laid
out he too who will accomplish the dream
of home ownership in due time but for
him a key component of that is getting
that income up which is probably the
case for many folks listening right now
but stay in the race keep putting that
money aside the time is going to pass
anyway this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
you are listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
your host today Jade warshaw joined by
George Campbell host of the Poppin
YouTube channel wow yeah Georgetown
scripture yeah all you got to do on
YouTube is go in and just Google George
camel right okay with a K that's right
and it'll show a friendly face and we're
having fun Jade I did some uh we did a
video on travel hacks yesterday because
everyone starts to travel for the summer
time ooh I shared my top 10. some some
good goodies in there can you give us a
little taste of what that of what one of
them I'll tell you how it ended it and
the last tip was me showing you how to
fly with luxury I'm talking you gotta
have the the noise canceling headphones
yes you gotta have one is like a little
flip flap you add to the little seat
yeah so you can put your phone up there
because I see everyone's struggling to
watch their movie and put it somewhere
where it's not falling I love that can
you inflatable uh headrest that's a big
one yes can you advise us on how to keep
the person in the middle seat in their
space instead of spilling with their
feet in their bag and and their chips
onto your seat because I guess 30
seconds are everything that is where you
you assert dominance yes so you gotta
command the elbow space and let them
know what's up yeah I puff up like a
blowfish on a Southwest flight
the other move you can do is just give a
little cough that usually will get them
to go I'm Gonna Keep Going can I tell
you the truth I tried that I did that oh
girl was really just getting into my
space look let it be known if you're
sitting in the middle seat you do have
access to both armrests that is again
I've heard that as an unspoken rule but
if you start putting your feet over into
my side and so I started coughing and
all she did she pulled up her blanket
over her nose like a mask but she didn't
move her foot I had one where like the
woman put all of her hair Behind the
Chair right in front of my face and I
was like this is not okay with me
as you can see her on the Ramsay show
that's really what the show is about
to call the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five we're talking
about money we're talking about travel
hacks apparently and how to keep the
middle seat person in their Lane Connor
from Jacksonville Florida what do you
know about it Connor
how are you guys doing good how can we
help
so the question I had is I'm trying to
figure out how to get my girlfriend on
board with budgeting now that we've kind
of moved in together okay what do you
mean kind of moved in together
that's a good question when you first
moved into my mom's place uh she moved
in with me and then we just got an
apartment back in January
so Finance has been like a big struggle
of ours and trying to get her on board
with like either every dollar or baby
steps it's been almost impossible what
is her is she just like no I don't think
that I should have to live in the what
she probably feels are confines of a
budget is that kind of where her heads
are kind of yeah so she finally got like
a pretty good paying job and her parents
just never taught her out of budget they
never budgeted so it's not really
anything that she was ever taught or
shown how to do that makes sense and she
she kind of just like oh as long as I
pay my bills I'm fine does she have debt
yes so right now it's about two thousand
dollars on a credit card and then about
000 in a car loan okay and you have no
doubt I have some debt I have a car loan
right now
um and then about a hundred bucks on a
credit card from gas how much is your
car loan by the way I just curious about
Seventeen five okay this is what I left
is why I O on it and you're done with
debt at this point
yeah well I just haven't spent on my
budgeting for the day I just got paid
but I mean like the concept of debt
you're like I don't want to be debt free
anymore like or I'm sorry I don't want
to take on debt anymore
yeah 100 okay so it sounds like you guys
have got to sit down and have some
lengthy conversation because right now
you guys have a different set of values
and it's not just as simple as me and
George going if you read this script
she'll say yes tomorrow to the budget
it's you guys sitting down and saying
okay we're living together we're
thinking about getting married or
hopefully we are about to get married
and before we get married or before we
get any deeper into this relationship
we've got to see that we have similar
values on how to live life because
honestly when it comes to money it
filters into so many areas of life this
is this is an exercise on how we view
life right when it comes to money and so
you would not want to enter into
marriage and in my mind even starting to
live with somebody is very shaky ground
if you don't see how to live life eye
eye to eye it's it's religion and it's
money those are some of the biggest
factors and how well a marriage is going
to play out how you raise your kids what
are your philosophies on that those are
the things that you need to be talking
about with somebody that you're thinking
about marrying and for sure somebody
you've already moved in with so what do
those conversations look like
so we've talked about budgeting the past
um her big thing right now is just she
wants to she's trying to get her credit
card paid off
okay so she's been putting like five six
hundred dollars a paycheck towards it so
we're trying to figure out if we should
just keep putting a lot of money in
savings and making like two or three
hundred dollar payments what do you mean
we are you saying you're helping her pay
this down
I'm kind of like helping her figure out
how to pay it down with her own money
yeah okay okay so we're not sharing
money just to make be clear
yeah we only share like grocery money
and rent pretty much that's it so you're
splitting the rent splitting the food
yes okay and let me just say in case you
were thinking of it do not split your
money like don't combine your money
don't pay off her debt she doesn't pay
off your debt
um and if
yeah let's just keep that clear this we
took I'm I'm just I feel the tension
building because we took a call
yesterday where a couple was playing
house like this they weren't married all
of a sudden she can't work or doesn't
work and now he's covering her bills and
paying her debts and it was a messy
messy situation and so I don't like this
idea us moral issues aside I don't like
the financial implications of living
together before you're married but as
far as getting her slope you asked about
how to get her on board budgeting and it
comes down to her wanting to take
control of her money and it sounds like
right now she's like well I pay my bills
so it's fine but I think you showing her
here's what budgeting has done for me
here's what mine looks like here's what
it's allowed me to do here's all the
things I've seen that I'm overspending
on I found out I can save money by doing
this I feel Con in control because I'm
giving every dollar a name that's the
stuff that makes you go I'm excited to
budget because the budget's not exciting
what the budget can do for me
financially that's exciting yeah and and
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be I'm a b Mama
Jade for a minute because I gotta say
this
you can't change folks you can lead by
example like what George is saying you
can you know hope that they get on board
by watching what you're doing and seeing
the impact it's making on your life but
when it comes to relationships you can't
change folks and I would advise kind of
putting a little bit of time limit on
this and kind of seeing like hey I'm
gonna put this out there and I'm gonna
see what her reaction is but after a
while if if old girl is still not on
board you're gonna have to see how that
lines up with your values and what you
want out of life and how you view money
and if you start if if she's like hey
I'm fine with this it's not it's not
important to me it's not something I
want to do you're then going to have to
decide what that means for the
relationship moving forward because let
me tell you you don't these are things
that matter you want to go into a
relationship you want to go into a
marriage with someone that you see eye
to eye with money fights and money
problems one of the leading causes of
divorce today so we just don't want that
for you Connor and I want I want you to
get out of debt and I think her seeing
you actually do this stuff and be a man
of your word will go a long long way
more than you telling her you got to do
a budget you should really her seeing
you become debt free a year faster than
her with having more debt she's gonna go
what what tell me what you did now what
is your income I'm curious
so mine comes right about 46 to 48 000 a
year depending on what I work over time
wise okay
and then hers I don't know what her
yearly is because her hours are weird
but her take home every month is 4 400
after tax okay
okay good so yeah this is just kind of
monitoring the situation right you're
being tactful about how you're talking
about it you are having open
conversation and ask direct questions
right don't skate around this be like
what's her name by the way well you
don't have to say her name let's call
her Jennifer Jennifer what do you think
about debt Jennifer I want to make it
clear you know in my life I don't want a
a life where we're borrowing money I
want a life where we stick to the budget
I want a life where there's parameters
around our spending and that's what I'm
seeking like let's have very clear and
it's not an ultimatum it's just you
being very Dave Dave Ramsey says to be
unclear is to be unkind
and that is what this is you guys have
been dating long enough you're moving in
together it's time to have these serious
conversations and make it super clear to
her this is what this is what I want out
of life is this what you want out of
life this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
hey what's going on everybody you are
listening to the Ramsey Show I'm your
host Jade warshaw joined by fellow
co-hosts George camel and uh listen if
you're financially ready to buy your
first home in this market it's not
because of luck it's probably probably
because you've been putting in the hard
work and kicking butt at budgeting and
saving and we're fired up for you we're
proud of you and we don't want your hard
work to go to waste buying a house is
the biggest purchase that you're ever
going to make so the last thing you need
to do is fly solo or work with a garbage
real estate agent even if it's your Aunt
Susan oh it's you it's always the family
members even if it's your Aunt Susan and
she's a very nice lady you know she goes
to church you can't leave this up to an
agent who's just good enough right you
need somebody who's great you need
somebody who's fired up they've been
doing it for a minute they know how to
make you some money you know what I'm
talking about a Ramsay trusted agent is
a great agent they set you up for
Success before and after closing day by
helping you find the right home keeping
you on track with your goals hey
time out because let me talk about that
because these agents that you tell them
I only want to spend this much and then
they're constantly showing you houses
that are outside of your price range
it's a trap nope so we need agents who
are keeping you on track with your goals
making sure that you're confident in
your decision in our Ramsay trusted Pros
or the Ramsay trusted Pros here on our
site uh can get our stamp of approval
because we know that they work hard to
serve you and they're not uh not to pad
their own paycheck so they're working
for you guys they're not trying to do
whatever makes the most sense for them
on the back end they treat our fans
right yes and so uh you've worked hard
to buy your first home and you don't
want to do that with anyone but the best
final Ramsay trusted real estate agent
by going to ramsesolutions.com agent
that's ramseysolutions.com agent and it
must be said my Ramsay trusted
real estate agent that I used nothing
but the best the best George I'm telling
you a resounding recommendation that's
right that's what we want to do so let's
take some questions uh our question of
the day is sponsored by neighborly your
hub for Home Services if you're moving
you have a long list of to-do's but
neighborly has local Pros like house
master or five-star painting or window
Genie or the Junk King to check items
off that list visit neighborly.com to
schedule your Home Service Experts near
you I might call call Junk King to just
go to my neighbor's houses and get all
that stuff out of the garage what is
people storing these days it's crazy
it's weird I see people they don't they
can't even Park their cars in the garage
they gotta Park them it's a free storage
unit why not it's craziness well today's
question comes from Marie in South
Carolina she writes I'm a huge fan thank
you for all you do to help people my
question is that I recently got engaged
and now have a beautiful ring and the
Jeweler said I needed to get my ring
insured is that necessary and what's the
best way to do that should I put it on
my homeowner's plan
yeah so I don't have a strong opinion on
this I think if it's something you're
worried about and make you feel better
and you have an exorbitantly expensive
ring that's a pretty big part of your
world it's not going to hurt to get
insurance on that and a lot of the times
you can do that through your homeowners
or renter renters policy and it may add
you know one percent of the value of the
Ring to your policy so five thousand
dollar ring might be 50 bucks a year
extra to insure that's good now I feel
like we have to caveat this because some
folks kind of go crazy on like the
warranties and like anytime I buy
something like on Amazon even you buy
one thing and they're like do you want
the protection or like Wayfair do you
want the protection on this and this is
not like an excuse to like go out and
get all the warranties and insurances on
all of the things right we are not a fan
of all these extras and warranties and a
lot of times it just makes the companies
a whole lot of money and that they know
statistically the chances of you needing
to use that and them actually paying out
and covering it and there's always
deductibles so you still have to pay
it's never just a a free lunch here so
you got to look into the fine print of
these and remember the reason for
insurance is to cover the things that
you can't cover that risk absorb and so
my role of thumb is if if that wedding
ring is going to tank you guys to
replace number one you may be getting
too expensive of a ring that facts that
scares me uh my wife's ring is not
expensive enough that is it's even worth
insuring yeah and she's a beautiful ring
let me just say that I believe that
George I believe you have great taste I
my wedding ring that Sam gave me the
first or engagement ring really we
insured it like the first five years
because back then it would have been a
big part of our world I think that if if
I had lost it and let's be honest the
man worked hard for it he had a paper
route and everything oh so he was a
grown man a grown man on a paper route
for some reason I pictured him on a bike
I know he was in a vehicle but him on a
bike like a little mini bike makes me
happy he's throwing those papers like
The Paperboy video game on Nintendo love
that game I mean we were in we're in
college and he he was like hey I've got
a paper route can I sleep on your floor
because you're close to my route and I
was like uh what
I didn't know that's what it was for and
then I found out that's what all I'm
saving up for that report all right
let's take a call we got Aaron in
Baltimore Maryland what's going on Aaron
hey how you guys doing doing good how
are you
you're good
um yeah I was just uh talking to the
gentleman um about to be uh losing my
job in about a year and a half shoot
coming from my uh six figure salary so
um that's a very specific and long time
frame yeah what's what's this scenario
surrounding this
yes it's an artist surrounding it is uh
I guess cold under attack in the United
States so uh basically long story short
is I guess they got in bed with Sierra
clubs so now we're shutting down and uh
we've got about a year and a half
um
of my salary income and Maryland I think
it's going to be a little bit more uh
difficult to find a six-figure income
coming from
um operations which I meant so uh right
now your skills transformed my time say
again your skills transfer to other
areas
yeah that's true it's true um however
um there's a nuclear plant down south
and the most the majority of the plants
are kind of a four probably like an over
an hour drive for me I mean there is
some smaller plants but uh so it could
mean that people are starting off
it could mean it could mean you moving
or transitioning to find the right
position
yeah I mean I I really do like the area
I live in
um but you also got to realize a lot of
these people that I'm working with we're
talking about 100 people are gonna be
losing their jobs so a lot of people are
going to be jumping it's going to
be very competitive trying to get a job
in these other power plants um plus I
have a family so some of these guys that
I work with are uh you know single guys
so getting up and moving is is not uh
not a daunting for them
have you started it sounds like you've
done a little bit of research let's do
more because I definitely would not wait
you know I would not ride this train for
the next one is there an alarm if you
got a job in six months could you just
leave
uh yeah so uh there's there's talks
about a retention bonus at my job but
obviously they're dragging their feet on
that so I mean at the end of the day
they're looking out for themselves and I
mean it is what it is business at the
end of the day but uh I mean the problem
with it is if you sign that retention
bonus obviously you have to stay to the
end yes so uh that's going to be a
problem so that's essentially your San
Francisco if you stick out for a year
and a half you get some kind of
severance
so they're talking about a retention
bonus and then stand at the end that
perhaps there could also be a severance
package as well but uh you know this is
all question marks right now and
honestly you know I have two young
children I don't need question marks in
my life we don't need any buzzer beater
Hail Mary situations so I would start
doing the homework now and sharpening up
that resume and going who do I know in
in these areas how what skills do I need
to transfer to maybe a different
industry completely that's right if coal
and power plants are going to be you
know a tough gig for you for the next 10
years we got to find something
sustainable and another part to that is
making sure that you're in the best
possible Financial shape right now going
into that so right now what's it look
like do you have savings do you have
debt can you roll that out for us
briefly
yeah so uh yeah briefly everyone out to
you so um I guess uh savings account I
got about 15 000 checking I got about
fifteen thousand uh I I did open a
little business recently
um with junk removal it seems like
everybody's moving investment just for
time how much debt do you have
all right so let's see uh
about 80 000 in car loans two hundred
and twenty thousand dollar in uh house
loans and eight thousand dollars on a
dump trailer and that's it all right so
this is what we're gonna do the game
plan is to do that research to find out
about work but in the meantime we are
cleaning up the mess of this debt we are
keeping a thousand dollars saved for
baby step one and then we're working
that debt snowball to pay off as much
debt as possible so that you can feel
comfortable going into this transition
and then of course any any and all extra
money you can pull in you mentioned you
had a side gig going on let's kick it
we're probably selling one or both of
these cars that's way too much car facts
for the situation you're in yeah you've
got some work to do but you can do it
Aaron we're pulling for you this is the
Ramsay show
so
[Music]
what's going on everybody I am Jade
warshaw your host joined by George camel
and you're listening to the Ramsay show
hey if you want to give us a call today
the number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five we'd be happy to
take your call but in the meantime we've
got our scripture and our quote of the
day this is my one of my favorite parts
of the hour George he says for God has
not given us a spirit of fear intimidity
but of power love and self-discipline
one version says a sound mind which I
love that one that second Timothy one
and seven and then of course we've got
this one from Alanis Morissette happy
birthday Alanis Morissette courage and
willingness to just go for it whether it
is conversation or a spontaneous trip or
trying new things that are scary it is a
really attractive quality so get out
there get crazy now we're not talking
about YOLO Atlantis it's different none
of that YOLO business where else can you
get some First Timothy and Atlantis in
one second I mean only on the Ramsay
show isn't it ironic
here we go got him it was really it's
not ironic at all but I had to say that
all right let's go to the phone lines
we've got Alyssa online one what's going
on Alyssa
Phoenix hi yes hi
um so my husband and I have been saving
for our home here in Phoenix for about
the past three years through covid we
are now priced out of the market and so
basically our question is should we stay
here in Phoenix and try to make it work
buying a house even if it might be some
Financial stress or should we move and
go out of state even though our friends
and family are still here in Phoenix
well
I appreciate the question but let's look
let's look at what you're saying here
because is it really
priced on the market I get it a lot of
people it's like yeah as fast as they
say that the prices just keep going up
right and it's hard to keep up with that
and outpace that so that you can
actually buy so completely valid I get
that but what you first said to me is it
is it worth it even though it would be
basically
you know beyond your means right you'd
be strapped for cash you'd have all
these issues no that's not worth it it's
absolutely not worth it if you're gonna
buy a house you want it to be a blessing
and never a burden that's not that's no
fun you'll start to resent the house
you'll hate the property it'll make you
dislike going to work right because
nobody wants to work just to be in that
rat wheel right George so that is a
no-go I feel like there's other options
that's right we can't live in Phoenix
we're getting out of the entire state is
there another option which is okay maybe
we do a town home that's 30 minutes out
of the city you know what I mean are
there other things you guys could look
at temper the expectations compromise a
little bit hey we're gonna save up for
another year whatever we can afford at
that time in whatever location in the
area we're gonna go for so where are you
guys at in in that regard
well we are currently living with his
parents
um have a baby so my husband's working
I'm at home with the baby
um
we currently have about eighty thousand
dollars saved for a down payment that's
great
um we we don't have any debt
um so we we really want to buy
um but we want to make sure that with
just one income coming in that we'd be
able to afford our mortgage and why is
there only one income coming in
I'm I'm a stay-at-home mom okay what's
he make sorry before you get to that can
I pause right quick George
um
I just want to challenge you on this
because George and I have talked about
this several times the dream is stay
being a stay-at-home mom so many folks
have that dream but you've got to ask
yourself in this season with what you're
saying you want Is it feasible are you
able to go into the marketplace and earn
more than the cost of daycare so that
you can accomplish this goal of getting
this down payment I just that's a little
sidebar for you to think of because a
lot of times we kind of feel like oh I
can just do this but then we complain
about what it means on the financial
implication so just throwing that out
there for you to think about okay George
that's a good word
so you're saying with his income
currently it's not gonna you're not
gonna be able to afford a home so like
Jade's saying what is his current income
he makes um 80 000
um with his nine to five and then ten
thousand with a side hustle awesome
about 90. okay
and you have 80 000 save what is a home
like the homes you've been looking at
how much do they cost
they're on average about 450
450. okay
so the take home on a 15-year fix which
is the only one I'd recommend if you put
80 000 down on a house that's 450 that
would be a thirty nine hundred dollar
mortgage payment
which is a lot of your take-home pay
right
yeah so just thinking about that number
you're going we couldn't breathe and so
that tells me we either have to temper
the expectations wait another year or
two and have 120 down or 150 down or we
need to go we're going to get a condor
town home because we don't want it or
like Jade said I may have to go back to
work for a season for the next year in
order to make this happen and one day
I'll be able to go back and accomplish
this stream in a way where it doesn't
set us back financially with our other
goals that's right because
mathematically you don't want to be more
than 25 of your take-home pay on that
mortgage otherwise you will feel the
strain it will be stressful and you're
gonna go like why did I do this so these
are the things that you've got you're
going to have to weigh out now don't get
me wrong I mean John deloney might say
yeah pick a place on the map and move
there you know you're free you can do
what you want and if that's if that
aligns with you guys is
you know personality then be my guest if
you're like look Phoenix peace out like
y'all are too expensive we're going to
Kansas then that's also up to you too
but I like what George said sometimes we
paint ourselves into a corner and it's
either we can do this or we can do do
that and those are only two options and
I'm hoping that we kind of illuminated
the fact that there's a lot of options
for you you've just got to decide the
main thing here is you've got to have
that boundary around we're not going to
buy a house unless we're able to buy it
the right way unless it's affordable and
it fits within those parameters 15-year
fixed rate mortgage where the payment is
no more than 25 of your take-home that's
what we're looking for great call Alyssa
I loved that
um let's go to Taylor right quick I
think we can handle it Taylor we're
slightly against the clock but tell us
about your situation
hi guys um yeah so my husband and I are
in babysit four so we're trying to
contribute our 15 we're both um
contributing to our 401ks and uh will
contribute to one Roth we're just not
hitting we're meeting that goal of 15
because I'm also trying to save for a
future surgery that we know it's going
to be about eleven thousand dollars okay
the question is is that okay for us to
just do what we're doing and then save
the money and handle that and then move
up to the 15 or in this stage should we
be pushing for the 15 while also saving
is there uh are you I mean not to get
too personal but is the surgery elective
or is it something that's like I gotta
get this done
it's something that we got to get done
okay I mean if you for your health if
you got to get done then you got to save
up for it yeah how quickly could you
save up let's say you invested you got
to 15 how much longer would it take
could you delay the surgery or is it
something that has a very specific
timeline
taking away from you know some margin
that is going towards that
um if I'm in your shoes here's what I
would do personally if this was my
family I'm gonna find a way to create
more income for the next year so that I
can invest 15 we have that going and I
can save up 11 000 for the surgery
because you're talking about a thousand
bucks a month to save up for the surgery
from scratch
do you guys have any money right now in
the bank
oh yeah we have our six months we have
18 000. okay great that's good that's
good and I love that you're not just
going oh we'll just use your emergency
fund to pay for it because in this case
it wouldn't be an emergency you know
what's coming yeah it's not unexpected
um so that's good I like that you guys
are doing that yeah I'm with George if
you have the ability to get your income
up and to still be able to do both
that's great if for I don't can't think
of a reason why but if for some reason
there's no option and it's you know
causing you guys to do some weird things
and maybe I mean I don't know if you're
in if you go down to
I just can't see it making a huge
difference going from 15 down to 13 yeah
yeah you can make a hundred bucks a
night doing a side hustle and if each of
you did that a few nights a week there's
your thousand dollars right there I like
that George so that would be my personal
goal uh if you need to scale back and
kind of call this a storm because this
is a health situation you need to scale
back investing we're not going to yell
at you right you're gonna be okay but my
personal goal would be to hit that
Milestone and save up on top of that
that's right thanks for the call Taylor
that's a great that's so good George you
know sometimes you really have to look
at the dollars and cents on something
and go all right is that if the
difference is 200 how quickly could I
make that you know do I really have to
pull from this or can I just go out and
get my there's always my fingernails
dirty that we're not thinking about
that's right I love it well guys that
does it for this hour of the show be
sure to join us next time and remember
you can tell me you won't do it but
don't tell me that you can't With God
all things are possible
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]